Welcome to the UK (and many more) as I explain CGP Gray
UK, England and Great Britain? Are these places the same place? Are they places
Different? Are the British secretly laughing at me who uses these terms wrong? Who knows the answer
These questions? I know and I will tell you now
To be lost: this is the world, this is the continent of Europe and this is where it is
We have to explain it. The area shown in purple is the United Kingdom
Part of the confusion is that the United Kingdom is not a single state, but a constituent state
From countries
Containing within it four equal and sovereign states
The first of them is England - illustrated in red - often mixed with England
And the United Kingdom as a whole because it has the largest area and the largest population of states
The capital contains the actual London
To the north, Scotland is shown in blue and to the west, Wales is painted white
And often forgotten even those living in the UK are Northern Ireland
Each orange has a local term for its inhabitants
While you can call them all "British" but not desirable because the four states in general
Do not like some
Northern Irish, Scots and Welsh consider the English slaves and colonial rulers
Regardless of whether the three have an independent parliament and are entitled to vote
On the English laws and that the opposite is not true - the English is considered
The rest are uncivilized villagers and spend a lot of time with their sheep
But since the constituent states of the United Kingdom do not have an independent passport, they are all
British citizens. they
British citizens of the United Kingdom (by the way the full name of the Kingdom of Britain
Great Britain and Northern Ireland)
So where does Great Britain hide?
Here: The black area is Great Britain. Unlike England, Scotland and Wales
Northern Ireland, Great Britain is a geographical term and not a political one
Great Britain is the largest island of the British Isles
In the UK, the term "Great Britain" is used to refer to England
Scotland and Wales with intentional exclusion of northern Ireland
This is mostly real, but not entirely, since the three states have islands
Not connected to Great Britain such as the Isle of Wight (part of England) and Anglesey Island
Welsh, Scottish Hippers, Shetland Islands and Orkney
And the Clyde Islands
The second largest island of the British Isles is Ireland
Ireland is not a state. It is like Great Britain's geographical term
And not political
The island of Ireland has two states, Northern Iranda (that spoke to us
) And the Republic of Ireland
When people say they are Irish, they mean the Republic of Ireland
A State independent of the United Kingdom
But both the Republic of Ireland and the United Kingdom are members of the European Union
Although England claimed to be a Mid-Atlantic island
Instead of the fact that it is 50 kilometers from the French coast. But this is a story for another time
for review:
The two largest islands in the British Isles are Ireland and Great Britain
Two states, the Republic of Ireland and Northern Ireland, while Great Britain
It contains (often) three: England, Scotland and Wales. When we gather these three
With Northern Ireland we get the UK
But there are many unanswered questions such as why you travel to Canada
Do you find pictures of the royal family on money? To answer this question, we will talk about the empire
It is impossible to be taught in countries that speak English without knowing that the British Empire
Expanded to a quarter of the world and ruled about a quarter of its population
While it is easy to remember parts of the empire that have been separated by violence
We often forget the states that have resigned through diplomacy instead of blood
These places, which are formed by forming a state that has reached an agreement with the empire, will continue to recognize it
That the monarchy is the head of state in exchange for an independent local parliament
To understand how to communicate we must talk about the crown
The real crown is not behind the glass in the Tower of London and brings millions of
United Kingdom tourists. But the crown as a complex legal entity is easy to think about
As a one-man company. Who started this company?
God started it. According to the British tradition all authority
Derived from the Creator and crowned ruler in a Christian ceremony
But God (does not want to be disturbed by the exact administrative details) and for ease is delegated
His power to the entity claims the crown. While this was used to refer to a particular crown
Preserved in the Tower of London, evolved over time into a legal company managed
Only by the king
It is useful to remember that the UK is still a religious state and the ruling king
Serves as the head of state and the supreme ruler of the official religion of the state
: Anglican. These are the difficulties we encounter when dealing with
A 1000-year-old property. We return to Canada and the rest of the former colonies
Which is independent during diplomacy and still recognizes power
The crown is known as the Commonwealth States and is in the descending order of the census:
Canada, Australia, New Zealand, Papua New Guinea, Jamaica, Solomon Islands, Belize, Islands
Bahamas, Barbados, Saint Lucia, Saint Vincent and the Grenadines, Grenada, Antigua and Barbuda
Saint Kitts and Nevis, and Tuvalu.
They are all independent states but still recognize ownership as head of state
That its authority is very limited within the borders of those States. There are three other entities belong
Crowns are Crown Dependencies: Isle of Man, Jersey, Guernsey
Unlike the Commonwealth countries, they are not considered independent states but are available to them
Local independence and British citizenship from the UK (but the Kingdom
Reserves the right to veto the laws of their local councils).
Have we finished "now"? Almost but not quite. There is still some there
Incomplete themes, such as this place, the small city of Gibraltar on the coast
The southern Spanish, famous for its rock, its monkeys and caused by diplomatic tension between
United Kingdom and Spain. And what about the Falkland Islands
Have caused great tension between the United Kingdom and Argentina to the extent of war between them
on her. These places belong to the last group of properties
The crown known as British Land Abroad. But its former name (Crown Colony) exposes its origin
It is the last remnant of the empire
British. Unlike the Commonwealth countries did not become
Independent states are still dependent on the United Kingdom for military assistance
And (sometimes) economic. And like crown dependencies all who are born within
Its borders are British citizens. Crown colonies are in the descending order of a census
Population: Bermuda, Cayman Islands, Turks and Caicos Islands, Gibraltar,
Virgin Islands, Akrotiri and Dekelia, Anguilla, St. Helena Asuncion Islands, Tristan da
Kona, Montserrat, British Indian Ocean Territory, South Georgia and South Sandwich Islands
Falkland Islands, British Antarctic Territory, Pitcairn Islands. And for the latter Finn model
The United Kingdom is located on the British Isles and is part of the Crown
Which is ruled by the monarchy, is also part of the Crown and the British Isles
Crown dependencies. Independent states of the former empire still recognize
Baltag are the countries of the Commonwealth, and the remains of the empire is independent
British territory abroad.
Thanks a lot for following up.